hello we're here with Billy Porter
I am nya Ward winner this evening
congratulations thank you for being here
thank you for having me so in your talk
you talked about access to arts
education as you probably know we
sponsor the excellence in theatre
education award through with the Tony so
our education is so important to us too
and you took that a step further with
access yeah let's talk about that a
little bit I mean what I mean by that is
you know I grew up in together a
Pittsburgh I didn't have people around
me who knew what to do who knew what
directions to take who knew how to get
me where I was desiring to be I had this
gift I had to tell it but like I said in
my speech I didn't even know what going
into high school that there was a such
thing as college and training in theater
for cut like I didn't even know that
that was an option you know so you get
there and you realize oh okay so those
are options now what are the best you
know what what are the you know like how
do you do it how do you pay for it you
know that's $20,000 a year I can't pay
for that that was the first thing I said
to my teacher when she said Carnegie
Mellon is one of the best drama school
it's down the street
that's where you're going I had no idea
was even here I didn't even know I was
ten minute drive down the street I
didn't even know that's what I mean by
access I had angels in my life at every
turn who were there to sort of push me
forward to lift me up to help me be in
the right place in the right time you
know somebody who explains what
financial aid was to me you know I
didn't know right that I could be poor
and a plot would and this is back then
because they're trying to take all of
that away but not her Negi melanson's
knock are you balanced I'm talking about
this current administration but you know
there were these programs all these
programs right that I could apply
I get grants get scholarships and pay
for my education because we do not all
start on the same playing field we don't
it's not I can't call my mother and ask
her for a million dollars to help me
start my company that's not what we come
you know and so to have somebody to have
somebody understand that right and
create a space for me to be able to grow
yeah
without access you know it's like giving
me accent giving giving us access it's
really important and that's one of the
things that you said when you were back
here in the hall doing a master's class
was that you have to show up for them
because other people showed up for you
yes those are those angels that you're
talking about absolutely absolutely you
know I had a cousin who was here today
oh good a cousin who was here today and
in college in high schools straight-a
student you know and nobody but at the
time for her to apply for colleges it
was me mm-hmm who told her you know
she's like oh I think I want to be a
lawyer you know as a paralegal I'm like
you want to be a paralegal or do you
want to be a lawyer well I don't know I
can afford to be a lawyer this is what
we're dealing with
why can't you afford to be a lawyer I
can't afford law school I can't afford
college I'm like but there are things in
place that can help you're a straight-a
black student
black female with nothing with no money
there are ways to get you to where you
need to be and where are the people who
are explaining this access to you where
are the people who are lifting you up I
had those people and I'm so grateful and
Carnegie Mellon was one of those places
you know once I got here it was like
okay I can do anything yeah that's great
you know I can do or be anything that I
want to be yeah and this year you also
got inducted into the Pittsburgh Public
Schools Hall of Fame and you had a bunch
of students here today
broan kappa support yeah i did that's
how i know they were coming
yeah really great it was really sweet
and you got to meet some of them what
did they have to say they're just
they're just they don't really say much
because they're so awestruck at this
point and I got to go I got to go down
there and like you know get a minute to
go down and like sit with the people in
touch of not my pantyhose on one leg and
a sidekick just like they momma's did I
do have to tell you I saw you in kinky
boots when you were here in Pittsburgh
yes first time I ever spontaneously yade
I just came out yeah I did I didn't even
realize I could do it well Billy thank
you so much it was such an honor to go
after you congratulations thank you for
coming back to this thank you for caring
about our students and about our cities
absolutely all matters are minor thank
you
and pick you guys for tuning in